- What's up, Believe Nation?
Welcome to another YouTube Hangout.
I am extremely honored to
have a very special guest
with me, somebody who's had a huge impact
not just on the world
but on my life as well,
the one and only Mister Tony Robbins.
Tony, welcome aboard, man.
- Thanks, Evan, great to be with you.
- Now before getting started,
I just want to express
my gratitude to you.
I know you've done so much
for the planet, for humanity,
but also for me personally, my family.
This book was one that
changed not just my life
but my mom's, she bought this
when I was six years old.
- Oh my gosh.
Still has her phone number
and her name is in here,
and it really touched her life,
and it was one of the
first books that I read
that was kind of an adult book.
And so, I just want to
thank you for the impact
you've had on me personally and my family.
It really has meant a lot.
- Oh that's very kind of you.
How old are you now, may I ask?
- What year is it?
It's 2018, I'm 38.
- Oh my God, since you
were six. (laughing)
I've been doin' this a little while.
Well thank you, I'm very complimented,
and give my best to your mom.
- I will, thank you.
We're here to talk about
your new book Unshakeable,
and what I found super
interesting about this,
it kind of feels like
it's your life strategies
just applied to the financial markets.
- [Tony] Yes.
- You open up the first page and it says,
when you're truly unshakeable,
you have unwavering confidence
even amidst a storm,
which is what you've been
teaching mindset-wise forever
but now applied to the financial markets.
Is that a fair assessment?
- Yeah, I think so
except it's really about
the strategies of how to do that.
It's not just about being confident.
What makes you unshakeable
is that you understand
the immutable patterns of the marketplace.
There are patterns just like
seasons that come about.
And what happens for
people, humanity transformed
from basically traveling
constantly from place to place.
We built communities once
we understood the seasons
'cause we can know when's
the right time to plant.
Most people do the right
thing at the wrong time.
And if you do the right
thing at the wrong time,
you get no rewards whatsoever.
In 2008, when I saw the markets
just crashing everywhere,
and I was working with Paul Tudor Jones,
one of the greatest,
top 10 investors in the
history of the world,
I've been working with him for 24 years.
He warned me, he showed me it was coming.
And during that time,
I did incredibly well,
and I was trying to tell
everybody what's happening,
and I was so angry about
the abuses that happened
that put us in that place.
And I thought within six months or a year,
something will be done.
And two years later, I
saw this documentary.
It was all about how
the meltdown happened,
and I realized nothing had changed.
And so, I said, you know
what, I have a unique gift.
I have access to some of the smartest
financial minds on Earth.
What if I interviewed 50
of the smartest people,
put it in a book?
So I did that over five years,
and I did MONEY Master the
Game, which was 675 pages.
Then I wrote this book
because I knew, look,
this is the longest running bull market
we've had in our history now.
We have a correction that's coming.
And most people make stupid
mistakes in a correction
that effect their whole life.
And I wanted to write a book
that whether you're a
millennial just getting started
or you are a baby boomer and
think you have no time left
to show you how you can
still win in any marketplace.
And the unshakeability comes from the fact
of understanding facts.
So for example, Evan, every single year
we have a correction on
average for the last 100 years.
A correction is a change
that's less than 20%,
usually 10 to 20%.
The average has been 14% during that time.
Now 14% drop gets people's attention.
You probably even remember two
years ago in 2016 in January
we had the worst opening in the history
of the stock market for January,
and we ended up having this
amazing year in the end.
People were freaked out.
I remember they were
reaching out to Davos,
Ray Dalio was there and CNBC went there
and said, what do we do?
The market's lost $2
trillion, now down 9%.
He said, pick up Tony Robbins' book,
I did and interview and I
shared with him my strategy,
how to make money in any
season, it's called all seasons,
and the truth of the matter
is, if you practice what he did
you're up 2% at that point.
So, I wanted to write a
book that would show anybody
how to go from where you
are to where you want to be
in the shortest time,
make you unshakeable,
not based on enthusiasm or confidence,
but based on understanding
the real patterns.
One other pattern and then
I'll throw it back to you
for your question but,
80% of those corrections,
80% never become a bear market.
So the market makes money 77% of the time.
That means three out of
four years, you're up.
That's a pretty great deal.
But because of people's fear,
their lack of understanding
of patterns, they overreact
and make dumb decisions.
I mean, the market's up
more than 300% since 2009.
If you got on on the worst day of 2009,
you got in on the day of the
crash, you're up 300% today.
But statistics show in
people's 401(k)s for example,
more than 30% of the people
stopped putting money in
back then and 2/3rds of the people reduced
what they put in their
401(k) because of the fear
of what happened 10 years ago.
So, you got to understand
that you got to be in the marketplace.
- There's a lot of talk
about control in the book,
what is the one thing that
you want people to understand
about control, when they
feel out of control,
they feel they don't
understand the stock market,
what's the one message you want people
to take home around control?
- I think it's that you
have to become an owner,
and not just a consumer, you
have to take a percentage
of what you earn, as
simplistic as it sounds,
and automate it so it comes
off the top of what you earn.
There's a gentleman that worked for UPS,
his name's Theodore, and Theodore Robinson
was this guy who never made
more than $14,000 a year
and yet he retired with $70 million
and gave away 35 million
while he was alive.
How did he do it?
He became an owner, his
best friend said to him,
"Listen to me, the most
important thing in your life is,
"we're going to put a wealth tax on you."
He goes, "A wealth tax,
I make 14,000 a year."
He goes, "We're going to make
you wealthy with this tax,
"it's not a government tax,
it's a tax to yourself.
"So we're going to take
20% of what you earn,
"and put it in an investment
account, let it build up."
He said, "I can't afford that."
He goes, "Once it's
automated, you won't notice."
That's all he did that
made him $70 million.
So it's like, people have to understand
that no matter how good
you are in business,
we all need a second
business with no employees,
and that takes very little time.
Something that, once you do your homework,
should take you 15 minutes to an hour
twice a year to rebalance, perhaps.
But outside of that, that's what this is,
this is setting up a business
that'll make you do well.
When I was, how old was I,
when I was 24 years old,
25 years old, I worked with
a man named Ken Blanchard,
who wrote those One Minute Manager books.
You probably remember him, Evan.
- [Evan] Yeah, I do.
- Really great guy, and I
helped him take five strokes
off his golf game and
that made me God to him.
And then he would say, I
want to return the favor.
And he goes, the best advice
I got growing my business was,
I was about to come
out with my first book,
and he said, a friend of
mine who's very wealthy said,
do not put that money in your company.
Let the leads go to your company,
do not let the profits go,
and do not spend those profits.
Put that in a separate account
that nothing ever touches,
'cause your business will eat
whatever resources you have.
A growing business does that.
And he said, "Tony, I put that aside,
"and during the tough times
that's what made me safe."
Well, I did the same thing with that
in my original infomercials.
That alone made me a wealthy
man, so when tough times came,
I could withstand it.
So I see so many business owners go,
yeah, but I have control of my business.
Bullshit, you have influence
over your business.
Yes you have more influence, but there are
better entrepreneurs than you
perhaps out there as well.
Or businesses that get greater valuations
than your business will.
And so your ability to grow,
you want to grow your own business.
I always tell people, you
want to build two businesses,
the business you're in and
the business you're becoming.
And that you want to have
the business that you're in
and becoming, and an investment business,
it's really simple once you set it up
and I think everybody's got to do that
if they really want to
have financial freedom,
because look, the marketplace changes,
competition changes, IBM was
the head of the pack forever
and then some little kid
from Microsoft comes along
and buys MS-DOS for $50,000
and then leases it to them,
and makes themself 3 billion
on that little move alone.
He didn't even write the software, right?
But you know, he's doing
great and all of a sudden
this little company comes along,
a couple of guys at Stanford
called Google, you know.
And Apple comes along, so
there's always disruption.
And the disruption could be competition,
it can be new technology, it
can be a change in the culture.
So even you you do everything
right you could lose.
I want people to have a back up plan,
this in the back up plan.
- I love it, and I want to dive deeper
into some of the tactics,
especially for entrepreneurs.
But first I had a personal question,
'cause it relates to chaos and control.
I love chaos, I love it when
the market's out of control,
it's why I love the stock
market, I love entrepreneurship.
I think a lot of my
audience can relate to that.
Where I struggle is actually internal.
I hate being out of control of my body.
So I've never been drunk,
I hate roller coasters,
never done drugs, even
going to your UPW last year,
I had a hard time fully 100% committing
because you lose control sometimes.
And I want to fix it, 'cause
I'm coming back in November
to UPW in New York.
- I'll see you then, that's awesome.
- I'm curious about what
your perspective is on that.
- Well, I look at control as a delusion,
right, that's the first thing.
It's your desire for
the illusion of control
that's pushing you, what
you want is certainty.
You want certainty you can avoid pain,
you want certainty you can have pleasure,
you want certainty you
can have a significant
and meaningful life,
we all want certainty.
But, learning ways to
control what you can control
is wonderful, but you
can't control most things.
What you can do is influence them.
And so the way I look at it and say is,
don't give myself the
delusion I have control,
'cause then I'll feel like
I've lost it at some point.
I never had control, I have influence.
I can influence my kids,
I can't control them.
I can influence myself,
I can influence what
happens to me financially,
can't control it completely.
And so I think if you give
up the illusion of control,
that loosens things up a little bit,
but I think the second thing is,
is to focus on what you can control,
which is what you think,
feel, and what you do.
And if I focus on the
things I can control,
I'm going to feel better.
I mean, all the research
shows that human beings,
when they feel out of
control, freak out inside.
And the more they fell they're in control,
the greater their self esteem.
And the way to have that
additional control is to say,
okay, what I can control is
what I do within the seasons.
You can say, I don't like gravity
and step off the side here, but
you're going to pay the price.
There're certain things that
are outside your control.
But you can use gravity.
I can fly a helicopter or an airplane
'cause I understand the
dynamics of how to do that.
If you understand the
dynamics of the marketplace,
you use the marketplace, the
marketplace doesn't use you.
And that's why I wrote Unshakeable.
I want people to have no more fear,
and when you start understanding
some of these statistics,
like, what's everybody
afraid of, a bear market,
a bear market is when
market corrects 20% or more.
Over the last 80 years they've happened
about every three to five
years, to give you an idea.
Later years, more five years.
Well, not we've gone the longest period
in history without one.
And yet, people are still afraid.
After every single bear market we've had
in the history of the United States,
it's led immediately into a bull market.
If you remember 2008, 2009, 50% drop.
In the next 12 months, the S&P was up 69%.
That's almost 70%, I can
show you every turn down.
So when you start seeing
that, it's immutable.
It's like winter comes,
but winter isn't forever.
And winter is a great
time to take advantage
'cause some people freeze
to death in winter,
other people ski and
snowboard and get by the fire.
Well winter, is when things are on sale.
If somebody said to you,
I got a $400,000 Ferrari
that you can buy for $70,000,
you'd probably grab in a heartbeat.
But if somebody takes
you a stock that was $400
and then 70 bucks, you're like,
oh my god, I can't do this.
You have to look at the cycles of history.
And when you do it, you become unshakeable
and more importantly, you become wealthy.
- So you talked about Ken Blanchard
and selling the business and having money,
and investing it back
into the stock market,
what would you tell the
start up entrepreneur who,
maybe is just getting started,
or maybe still has a full time job,
and it feels like every
dollar that they're making
they're just trying to build
their business at the moment,
they haven't cashed out yet.
Should they be investing
into their business,
should they still be saving
some to put into the market,
what would you tell that person?
- I think you have to put
something outside your business
because what's the number
one rule of investing
that even idiots understand?
Don't put all your eggs
in one basket, right.
And what do 90% of entrepreneurs do?
Because of the illusion of control,
they go, I'm going to put
all my money in my business.
Don't get me wrong,
it's still a great place
for your money and for your
time and for your energy.
But you got to take a
piece of what you earn
and you got to bet on
some other entrepreneurs
and get outside yourself specifically.
And if you look at, you know,
somebody like Warren
Buffet'll tell you, look,
he said, "All my wealth is
a result of a couple things,
"some good genes and compound interest
"and living in America."
So, if all you do is get
compound interest on your side,
the game changes, you don't
have to have a lot of money.
What Ken Blanchard told me to do,
that wasn't when I sold the business,
I was in the business, it
was requiring so much cash
from me and he was saying, no
matter how much cash you have
the business will demand it.
You got to take this
percentage and set it aside
and not give it to the business.
I had a situation at one
point where I went through
a divorce, I initiated it,
but it was a brutal divorce,
quiet frankly, and when
I married this woman
she had no money and I
lived in Delmar Castle.
When I got divorced, she
got an eight times multiple
on my businesses, and I had
to pay her a million dollars
a year, for 18 years, and
I was only married to her
for 14 years, plus $42 million.
So, I can tell you beyond
a shadow of a doubt
that I woke up every day before
I could feed my own family
and had to pay this woman a million bucks.
And I had to pay the taxes on it.
And the only way you can
do that is automate it,
and forget about it, and add value,
focus on how to add
value in your business.
So I took it as a tax, off the top,
I never looked at it again,
and I just automated it,
and I got to be honest,
the first six to 12 months
it made me a little crazy,
'cause I'm workin' my guts out,
and she's not, but what happened was,
after awhile, my skill increased.
And what I've found is anybody
who's done this in business,
even the very beginning and say, look,
if the government came in right now
and put a 15% additional
tax on your business,
you'd scream, you'd yell,
you'd say, I can't pay it,
and you'd f'in pay it.
But the difference is,
the compounding here's what's different.
I tried to explain compounding like,
think about if you want
to tell a kid this.
If you take a 19-year-old kid,
that's got a little job and you say look,
I want you, it sounds like a lot,
but I want you to put aside $300 a month
but let me show you why.
300 bucks a month set
aside, thrown in the market,
average market return's been 8%,
it's been 10% over 100 years,
but most recent 30 years, 8%.
So, let's say you get the
average return, and it compounds.
That kid who starts at 19 with 300 a month
can stop at 27, he's only
done it for eight years,
never put another dime in,
and he's only put in 24 or $28,000,
but that'll grow to 1.8 million
without putting another dime in.
That's the power of compounding.
28 grand, 1.8 million.
If his best friend starts
at 27 when he quits,
and invests every single
year, all the way to 65,
and he puts in the same $300 a month,
he puts in 140 grand, and in that time
he's got $400,000 less money.
So, it's not the amount of
money, it's the amount of time.
Time is your greatest friend here,
and if you get in the
game, you're going to win.
An you need to get in the game now,
not wait 'till your
business is successful.
- How do you decide what percentage
you want to allocate to investing?
- That's a great question, if you look at
what you want to have in the end,
you hear very often
financial advisors today
still use this crazy number, they'll go,
well you need like, if
you make $100,000 a year,
you need a million bucks.
And that's the biggest lie on the planet.
That was for the days when
you might be able to get
a 10% return, I don't what
days you could do that
totally secure, maybe back
when interest rates were 18%.
But, there's no way that
you're going to get a secure
environment, the whole idea
is to build your money up,
build your assets up, and
eventually have the income
take care of you for
the rest of your life.
The only reason you invest is for income.
Income'll buy you your trips,
it'll put your kids through
college, it'll pay for your
home, it'll give you food.
People think they want assets,
assets can go up and down
for any period of time, so
you want put in a secure place
at some point, where the
income provides all you need
for the rest of your life.
Well, pretty hard to do
that if you're putting that
in an environment where
you're trying to get 10%,
it's not going to happen.
So you really need 20 times your income,
that's really the number
that most people should be utilizing,
which doesn't sound very compelling.
But when you understand
compounding like $300 a month
for eight years, turns into 1.8 million,
never put another dime
in, you start to go,
hm, maybe I can still win this game.
We don't think geometrically,
we think step at a time.
And the way stocks work, or
the way any investment works,
there's compounding, and the compounding
is the greatest gift that we have.
- So I guess it depends
on your age for how much
percentage of your money--
- Well to specifically
answer your question, I would
do as much as you could,
but I would say 10% would be the minimum,
and you ideally want to build to 15 or 20.
And they did a study for people who said
they had no ability to invest,
they had no money whatsoever,
and it was done by this
group of professors
that were eventually
nominated for a Nobel Prize.
And what they found was, if
they got them to put aside 3%,
and anyone can do 3%, and
then with every additional
increase in salary, they
put another 3% aside,
within 15 years, the average
person was saving 15%.
65% were saving 19%.
These are workers in middle class America,
making $35,000 a year,
to give you an idea.
And at 19 or 20% you become wealthy.
You'd have to screw up to
not make it at that point.
But if you think about
it, today most people
are going to retire, based
on actuarial statistics
for no less than 20 years,
some of them 30 or 35 years,
well they only worked for 40 years.
And most people did
not set aside the money
to make that happen, so
that's why I wrote this book.
I want to do something so
simple you can read in a weekend
and say, okay, here's
where I'm being screwed
and I'm going to save
all that money alone.
Just the savings you can make
on not overpaying in fees,
every 1% in fees you pay
more than you should,
is 10 years of income you
give up in retirement.
Because they're compounding.
We know that compounding
works on appreciation,
but compounding also works on fees.
So you got to understand that.
In Unshakeable I walk you through it.
'Cause you cannot believe the abuses
that happen in this system.
- You talk a lot about the
house and how you're bettin'
against the house and the
house always makes money.
So if somebody's now listening to you
and they say, okay
great, 10, 15%, 20 maybe,
I'm going to save, what's my next step?
I don't get the stock market,
I don't know what to do next,
I'm not going to give it to a mutual fund.
What's my next step?
- Well I'm glad to hear you
say you weren't going to
give it to a mutual fund
because most people don't know
that 98% of all mutual
funds in any 10 year period
do not even match the market.
So if you're going to buy
something in that area
and you're going to start out simple,
you want to buy the Index
because it's so cheap.
But you got to think about,
where do most people put their money?
They put it in a 401(k),
that's where 90% of Americans
have the largest sum of
money, it's their home
and their 401(k) and the 401(k) is bigger.
And the problem is, like you said,
people don't know where to go.
So what I tell people first step,
make the most important
financial decision in your life,
that you're going to pay yourself first,
so there's going to be some money
you're going to keep forever
for you and your family,
not give it to Kate Spade,
or to Amazon or anybody else.
Here's that percentage and automate it,
so you don't see it.
Second step is, now we
got this bucket of money
we're building up, where
the hell do I put it?
And in that case, the most
important financial decision,
investment decision, I
should say, is the decision
of asset allocation,
which is a big word for,
how much money do you put
at low risk environments,
where you probably get smaller
returns, but less risk?
How much do you put in
higher risk environments,
like the stock market or real estate,
where you have unlimited
upside but you also have
unlimited downside as well?
And so how do you balance that out?
And the answer to the question,
we walk you through in the book
how to make those decisions,
but here are some of the criteria.
Your age, as you said, is number one
because how much time do you need
before you need this money is huge.
If I'm in a position, and
let's say I got two buckets,
a secure bucket, low risk,
you know, low returns,
a risk growth bucket, more risk,
more growth, or more loss.
What percentage, do I put
like 60% secure, 40% here,
do I do, 20% secure, 80% at risk?
And that has to do with number one,
how much time do you need?
So, if you need the money in five years,
you can't afford to take giant risks,
'cause if you screw up, you got no room.
If you're 20 years old,
hell, you can screw up
many times and still win the game.
So, that's number one.
Number two is, what's your risk tolerance?
And in the book we have
some tests for you,
'cause what people think
their risk tolerance is
and what it really is
are two different things.
We play a game at one of
my seminars where I say,
I put some music on and say,
make change with people around you.
And they go, what?
I go, make change, so they
reach in their pockets
and start making change.
And it ends after one
song, four or five minutes
and I go on to the next subject
and inevitably somebody
stands up and goes,
I want my money back, this f'er over here
took a hundred bucks
and gave me five bucks.
And I go first of all, what
makes you think it's your money?
And I said, second of all,
what makes you think the game is over?
And if somebody's stressed
about a hundred bucks,
and you're going to be an investor,
you're going to be in trouble.
So you got to know your risk tolerance.
And then last, what's
your access to cash flow?
If you have a lot of
extra access cash flow,
you've got room to take more risks.
If you don't have much cash flow,
you're going to have to be more selective
in what you're going to put at risk.
- How important is the
education side in that,
should I just be putting
my money into the Index,
and I don't have to worry about it,
it's going to go up seven to 10% a year,
and pay super low fees,
versus, I need to understand
the actual stocks to buy, if
Amazon's a good buy or not.
How much do you advise
understanding the individual
companies, or should it just
be kind of set it, forget it,
buy the Index, look at it once a year,
then don't worry about it?
- I don't think you want
to just do the Index
because you want to have
different asset classes.
If you look at the best
investors in the world,
they all understand that
they're going to be wrong.
You talk to Ray Dalio, the
greatest hedge fund investor
in the history of the world,
guy made a fortune in 2008
when everyone else was losing money,
and what does he tell you?
He says, "Tony, you have to have money
"in each different asset class because
"different environments, the
environments will change,
"no matter how smart
people think they are,
"they're going to be wrong.
"And you got to structure yourself
"so you're able to make
money no matter what."
So you don't want just the Index.
But, what you do want to do, is
you do not want to be probably
somebody who's trying to
evaluate individual stocks.
That's really somebody who's
going to try and be a trader,
and in most cases that's
not going to work.
Now if you're Warren Buffet,
that's a different piece.
But it may be better to
invest with Warren Buffet,
who's better at selection than you are,
than you trying to do it.
Stock picking, nobody wins at it.
The best in the world don't win.
You got people that are suppose to be
the best hedge fund guys on Earth,
and what's their track record
over the last seven years?
It's pathetic, they've not
even matched the market.
And so that's why you've
seen this shake up
in the hedge fund industry.
'Cause after you pay for fees,
even with their brilliant minds,
you end up lower than if you
just own the market itself.
So the answer to your question
is you need to diversify.
Let me give you the four things if I may,
that are the four most
important things that I found,
they were the only things in common,
I interviewed 50 of the
smartest financial people
in the world but they all
have different approaches.
You look at Warren Buffet, he
has a very different approach
than say, Ray Dalio does, right?
One's looking at trends in the market,
the other's looking at
individual companies
and trying to take advantage
of the best possible
valuations that he possibly can.
But here's what they all
agree on, number one,
and I know this sounds basic,
they're obsessed with not losing money.
Most investors are obsessed
with trying to make money.
But because they know
that if I lose $100,000,
and I want to grow it back,
I can't just go and grow
at a small rate to make that happen.
Let's say I lose 50%
of it, I have $50,000.
How much do I got to grow to get even?
Most people say, well you
lost 50%, you got to grow 50%.
They don't realize, if you had $100,000,
it's only worth 50 now, you
got to grow 100% to get even.
So the smartest investors know
they're going to be wrong,
and they have an asset allocation,
they've broken up their assets in a way
that even if they're wrong,
it's not going to hurt them severely.
Second, this is the one
that's more interesting,
they all are obsessed with this idea of,
how do I have the least amount of risk,
with the most amount of return?
They call it asymmetrical risk reward.
And what they look at is,
when I started working
with Paul Tudor Jones,
one of the 10 best investors in history,
he had lost money for some time.
He had been the most successful investor,
and the meltdown that happened, you know,
the largest stock market
in history meltdown
that we had, where you lost 20% in a day,
he made 200% that year for his guys,
and made I think, if I
remember right, 40% that month.
I mean, this is a
brilliant, brilliant guy,
but here's how he does it.
He doesn't invest like most investors.
He doesn't say like, where
can I get a nice return?
He's lookin' for a five to one.
Where if he risks a dollar,
he believes he'll make five.
Now he's going to be wrong, he
knows he's going to be wrong.
So if I risk a dollar, try
to make five and I'm wrong,
okay, I can risk another dollar.
He can risk four out of five
dollars and still make money.
So, that puts you in a
very different position
than most people.
If you look at somebody like,
Richard Branson's a friend
and Richard is just a genius as you know,
but what most people don't have a clue
is when he started Virgin Airlines,
he only started with five airplanes,
giant investments, right,
these Boeing business jets.
But what people don't know is
he spent a year negotiating
so he had no downside.
If he didn't succeed in
the first three years,
he negotiated a deal
to give back the planes
with no credit lost, nothing lost to him.
So it was all upside, and no downside,
that's called asymmetrical risk reward.
Kyle Bass is a friend of mine.
He is well known during
the 2008 crisis because
he took $20 million and
turned it into four billion,
in the worst economic environment
we've had in 80 years.
And how'd he do it?
Well I could explain the details,
but he bet against real estate
when everybody else was betting on it,
he looked at the facts.
But here's the secret, every
time he invested six cents,
and in order to risk six
cents, his upside was a dollar.
So if you risk six cents,
you can be wrong 15 times
and still make money.
Well he wasn't wrong
15 times, thus he made
two billion out of 20
million in 3 1/2 years.
So, asymmetrical risk reward
is what they're looking for.
You can't always get a five
to one, a three to one,
but you want to be looking
for it, and you want to
think differently than the average person.
Third, they're all completely
obsessed with tax efficiency,
but not until they first
have done the first two.
If you just try to do
something based on taxes,
it's not the right investment.
But if it's something where
you can feel relatively certain
you won't lose money, and you've set up
the asset allocation that if
you're wrong you're still okay,
and then you've got
tremendous risk reward,
small risk, big reward,
then you want to make sure
it's tax efficient, 'cause as
I've trained all the people
that work for me, don't
tell me the return,
tell me the net return,
tell me after taxes,
after fees, after everything,
'cause it's very different
than what people do.
And so, if you take a dollar,
and you know compounding,
and you double it 20 times,
it's a million and 48,000.
But if you just paid 33% in tax,
which is less than most
of what your viewers
probably are, I should say more than what,
less than probably what most
of your viewers or listeners
probably pay, most would probably be
more in the 50% tax range.
And you think about
it, that 33% taken out,
after 20 turns, you think
well, how much is that,
it was a million and 48, you take out 33%,
well that's only 330,000,
roughly, around 300 grand.
No, no, no, that math doesn't
work, this is compounding.
Instead of a million and
48,000, if you pay 33% tax
each year, you have $28,000,
instead of a million and 48.
So tax efficiency baby, is huge.
And then the last one is,
what I talked to you about
from the beginning,
which is, every investor
believes in diversification
across multiple elements.
In other words, you don't
want to just buy real estate,
you want different
assets, or just the Index,
like you described, that's a disaster.
'Cause there'll be times
when the Index will get hit,
and you need something to balance it out.
If you're only in one place
you're going to get hurt,
and the pain will be so
strong you'll probably sell
and then have a permanent
wound or a permanent problem.
You don't want that to happen.
So you need diversity
across different assets.
You don't want just one
giant piece of real estate.
You want diversity within asset classes,
so multiple pieces of real estate,
or owning the Index as the example.
You want diversification
across different economies,
and you want diversification across time,
which is what dollar
cost averaging can do.
So, those are four things
that the greatest investors
on Earth all do in common,
even though they have different
approaches to making money.
- I love it, I love it,
wow, we got to rewind that
a couple times to really let it digest.
I know we're bumpin' up
against the clock, Tony.
Guys, who are watching, live, the replay,
the book is linked up in
the description below.
UPW, if you want to see
me as well in New York
in November, is linked up below.
Tony, the third link we
have in the description
is about your Feed America campaign.
You're trying to feed
100 million families.
Do you want to just quickly
talk about that for my audience?
- Yeah, we've actually
fed 100 million every year
for four straight years.
This year we'll hit 400
million, I committed to feed
a billion meals over the next 10 years,
so we're six years out from the billion
but I'm really pleased with it.
But every book, the book has
just come out in paperback,
so everybody knows, so please pick it up
and if you do pick up, 50
meals will get paid for.
I donate 100% of this
book's revenues, everything,
to Feeding America, and
if you want to join me
and go to Feeding America,
every dollar you donate
I will duplicate, meaning
if you put in $100,
I'll put in 100, if you put in a million,
I'll put in a million, up to four million
each year, to give you an idea.
So, love it if you take advantage of this,
change your own life with Unshakeable,
you can read it in a
weekend, but you'll also
be helping those in need.
And right now, we're the
richest country in the world,
we got 49 million people who don't know
where their next meal's
going to come from.
17 million are children, I was one of them
so it's not a stat to me, and
that's why I'm doin' this.
So, hope people will pick up the book,
hope it will help them touch their lives,
but also it'll change other
lives while they're doin' it.
- I love it, well we've linked
all three of those things
guys up in the description below.
Tony, we've got a minute and a half left,
final message for my audience?
- I would just say look if you're,
you have a lot of
entrepreneurs in your audience
and I have 54 companies
myself, we do about six billion
in business, a little more than that now,
and I can tell you, I had
no background in business.
What made me as effective
was that I wouldn't
get involved in a business
just to make money.
I'm involved with a business
'cause it's a mission,
it's something that I think
can change somebody's life.
And whether it's something as simple as
the stem cell business,
or whether it's LAFC,
a soccer team I own, or
whether it's a resort in Fiji,
I try to do something that's
going to change their lives,
and the whole focus in
business is add more value.
There is no other rule.
If you do more for others
than anybody else does
in the marketplace, you'll build a brand.
People get on their knees
and reach behind a soda pop
to get a Coca-Cola, even
though Coke doesn't win
most of the taste tests, it is the brand.
You'll become the brand if
you can do more for others
than anybody else does, and
I hope that your audience,
the reason they're listening to you,
is to figure out how to
add more and more value
to the marketplace.
And the last thing I'll say to them
since they're entrepreneurs
is find who your ideal customer is,
and build your business around that.
The customer that's going
to do the most with you,
the customer that's
going to refer the most,
the customer that when winter does come,
will still buy from you.
Find out who that is and over-service them
and you will have no difficulty
growing your business.
- Tony Robbins, ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you so much, man,
I'll see you in November,
and I really appreciate
you taking the time today.
- Thanks for having me
on, take care brother.